non là c'est que je vends des prises
[Musique]
prenez pas la carte de fidélité
au pire
[Musique]
noël est back soon nos deux plus gros
mois de l'année
c'est à dire que ça fait à peu près
trois fois les mois normaux chaque
chaque période alors que là ce sera même
pas à la moitié d'un mois normal
alors ça c'est noir ça select
nous
[Musique]
je reçois ici dans les magasins les
demandes
je dois les préparer et a précédé
collins et des colis pour les jls il ya
quelqu'un qui vient de récupérer les
libérateurs mais quand même il ya des
clans qu'il pouvait lire il l'a récupéré
dans l'après midi
[Musique]
ça doit être un peu la fête mais ça ne
l'est pas tout à fait pas oublier ce qui
se passe ça va être particulier ben on a
une grande terrasse avec plein de fleurs
et on a déjà prévu en fait de cacher les
petits adorent les fleurs et tout mais
bon on pourra pas sortir
[Musique]